نعم للمفاوضات دون شروط مسبقه باستثناء
الشرط الاساسيه واحد حسن النيه من كيف
هكذا جاء اعلان موسكو انفتاحها على الجلوس
مجددا الى طويله الحوار مع الاوكرانيين في
ايام تصيد العسكري للحرب الداميه هل ذلك
ممكن واي دور ستؤديه واشنطن تهامه
بتعطيل العمليه
قال ان اوكرانيا هي التي تبنت قنونا
يمنعها من اجراء مفاوضات سلميه مع روسيا
وان بلاده تعلن دائما استعدادها لمثل هذه
المفاوضات التي لم تقطع بسبب روسيا كان
الرئيس الاوكراني
وقع في الرابع من اكتوبر الماضي
على
انفاق اي محادثات مع بوتين منعلمه اريد
انه ترك الباب مفتوحا لاجراء حدثات مع
روسيا لذلك جاء التعليقات مستشار زلينسكي
على التقارير الصحفيه الامريكيه بشان
المفاوضات متناغمه جدا مع هذا المبدا
اوضحها ميخائيل بولياك انكيف لم ترفض ابدا
التفاوض وموقفها معروف ينبغي سحب القوات
الروسيه اولا قبل الحديث عن اي تفاوض
مضيفا جمله نحن واضحون في تقييمنا سنتحدث
مع الرئيس القادم لروسيا
احجم كل طرفين عن الخوض بالتفصيل فيما
ذكرته تقارير واشنط بوست
كيف كانت على اي مستوى جرت الاتصالات
المباشره وغير المباشره بين الامريكيين
والروس في الاونه الماضيه وهل فعلا ضغطت
واشنطن على ثياب للقبول بالجلوسي الى
طويله الحوار حتى في ظل وجود القوات
الروسيه على ارضها
برد مستشار الامن القومي جاك سوليفان
المحادثات السريه التي اجراها مع كبار
المسؤولين الروس لانها كانت تهدف الى الحد
من المخاطر وتقليص احتمال وقوع كارثه مثل
استخدام السلاح النووي
الولايات المتحده لدى الامم المتحده ليندا
الولايات المتحده مستعده للوقوف الى جانب
اوكرانيا طالما لازم الامر الحد قولها
مضيفه ان اي مفاوضات يجب ان تكون مع
اوكرانيا وقادتها يقررون مدى استعدادهم
لذلك من كل اللقاء
التركيز على مساله ضروره تنديد اتفاق
تصدير الحبوب بعد التاسعه عشر من الشهر
الكريم
اعاده بعض الحسابات والعوده عن للهات مثلي
عدم التفاوض